this is a production of Cornell
University okay so I'm primarily a
vegetable grower and been working with
cover crops for almost three decades and
so today I'm going to talk about kind of
a pastiche of different techniques that
I've used on my farm for different
reasons and you know really the idea is
is how on a intensely managed vegetable
cropping operation can you fit cover
crops into where those vegetable crops
are grown and and for myself personally
I didn't start I didn't grow up on a
farm I grew up in suburbia and central
Illinois and I didn't go to school
University in that and agriculture or
even science for that matter I was
English an Asian Lit major and so I
really got into agriculture by by
reading reading poetry really and so I
thought there'd be a nice to start off
with appropriate poem which talks about
cover crops really frost seeding by
Wendell Berry and it seems appropriate
now even though this is data in February
2nd 1968 in the dark of the Moon in
flying snow in the dead of winter war
spreading families dying in the world
danger I walked the rocky hillsides
sowing clover so Wendell here is a frost
seeding covert and probably has a nice
heavy clay soil which frost seeding
works much better on than the farm where
most of my farming experience came from
southern New Hampshire and that where we
had a sandy loam
know everybody today has been talking
about all the beneficial effects of
cover crops and green manures and just
just kind of reiterate some of them is
the allopathic effects on the weed seed
bank interruption of pests and disease
cycles elevated microbial activity in
soils positive effect on soil moisture
conservation legging family fix anywhere
from 50 to 300 pounds of nitrogen per
acre and the attractive capability of
cover crops for beneficial and
pollinating insects and of course
addition of organic matter to your soils
to promote soil health so I'm just going
to start with some profiles of different
cover crops on that and and these are
really very common used in the upper
north northeast winter rye our winner
Ryan combination with hairy vetch and
run through some photographs where I've
farmed in southern New Hampshire up to
Midcoast Maine there's a ideal windows
for getting in some of these cover crops
as Thomas was definitely talking about
with some of the cover crops he was
talking about you know winter rye
there's a pretty long period of time
that you can get your eye on from late
August all the way into about now if you
want to gamble a little bit but the
window is much shorter for hairy vetch
and I found that really mid-august to
mid September is the ideal time to get
that vetch in in especially in
combination with your winter rye and
these two in combination over winter
really well the kill time or the
termination time for rye would be very
early in the spring if you can get into
the fields and with the tilling stage or
allow it to get to full maturity and add
to the pollen stage and then mow it at
the pollen stage
and with the veg component in that and
with tillage and there is a lot of
tillage with vegetable crop rotations in
that the mineralisation they'll come off
the rind batch will you know feed most
of your cash crops for a midsummer into
into later in the fall so it's a great
great setup crop with no the use of
winter rye
it catches really nicely with just soil
moisture net and so for fall kind of
widely spaced single row or crops
there's a great opportunity to get rye
into your field while you're still
growing your cash crop in this case
broccoli transplanted in August and the
Rye is just spun on in mid-september
it's critical that your your broccoli
planning is clean from weeds and that
but you don't need to press it in or
cultivate it in and that you can just
spin it on with the moisture net you can
get a pretty good catch on most years
broccoli will continue and the growth
slows down in that shaded area where the
where the broccoli is and then much
later after Rocky's been cut off and
this case this feel it's much too wet to
get in there with implementing that have
a nice stand of winter rye to get you
through the winter
I learned this trick from Thomas from
his website and that and that is that
sometimes you have a field where you
didn't get a cover crop in in in the
late fall in the winter it's bare it
could be weedy
and you schedule something that would go
in there say and in June that that kind
of bare window of time it's a great time
to put down some cheap seed like rye and
you'll flush some annual weeds through
that you'll kind of stimulate the
microbial soil life and that with that
rye and and also it will be scavenging
some leftover nitrogen than that so you
can use this rice really like a starter
fertilizer the trick is not to let it
get very much growth four to six inches
and then the tillage don't need
aggressive tillage analogies the perfect
to pass the perfect of the field was
ready to go and then I was able to
transplant summer summer squash and in
winter squash and this little block here
but to basically use it as a bio
stimulant and in a weed suppressant for
many years of work with the idea of
obstruent of rye over whenever Ryan veg
and instead of using a crimper and app
which will kind of kill your Ryan
veteran app but the ground stays kind of
cool in a crimper most of my farming
experience is a little further north in
the Northeast and I want that soil to
warm up in that for what I intend to put
into these strips and that so I I would
with a Spader
early in the spring cut strips in my
field of overwinter dry and vetch
and then is able to direct seed winter
squash our pumpkins and the alternating
strips what strips are wide enough that
that soil gets warm before I put the
seed in and I let the right vet continue
to grow so I'm getting a fair amount of
some straw mulch from that and then then
at that termination time which is the
the winner dry and a pollen stage and
vetch we gain to the flower this case is
probably a little bit far advanced and
that mow it down and you have a nice
straw between your between your beds of
winter squash our pumpkins still able to
cultivate the pumpkins the grounds warm
there and then and then kind of
refinement of this technique if I want
to get a fall cover crop in the field as
hard to get a cover crop in when at the
time with the squash and pumpkins would
come off in mid late September in that
using the it's kind of establishing
living mulch strips of medium red clover
and so just at the stage of where the
tendrils start to move out on the
pumpkin plants here and that movement is
very quick I'll do a shallow tillage and
then drop clover seed in it's very
important that there's moisture to soil
to get good germination the color Packer
press that seed in it'll germinate
different field same thing and then the
the broad leaves from the pumpkins or
winter squash and that shade that clover
so the shape the clover doesn't really
interfere with the growth of the winter
squash and that and then as the squash
and pumpkins comes out of the field in
that very important to get it out of the
field as quickly as you can mow off that
that crop residue and that so the the
clover strips can get light and then
you're in the fall I'm it's that you
know I get my my fall cover crop
established but it was seeded back in
July and with the liberation of light to
the clover net then it'll fill in this
fill in the field and that different
field here at butternut same thing the
butternuts come out strips are there
and here we are in November and then
that clover has filled in the field and
then next spring yet you know really
nice clean stand of clover and yet in
the nitrogen that's coming off that
clover and then I'll flip families on
that so I'm using establishment with a
cubit family and they'll cut strips in
that field of red clover and I'm
transplanting Tomatoes it's kind of hard
to see the tomato plants very small on
this slide and and and so I'm just kind
of changing plant families and I use the
clover it's a straw mulch for the
tomatoes
Johnny's you know they were a little
hesitant to see some of these techniques
brought on to their farm so you're just
kind of like a little bit of refinement
this technique this is last spring in
that on fields there's a lot of crop
residue we've got the plastic out and
and basically Herald a field marked
marked all my beds and then any bed that
I was going to have on plastic plastic
whoops plastic mulch i seated seated all
in any strips to oats and in medium
medium red clover the oats is a nurse
crop for the clover use a collie part
pack it in and then I continued with the
spot transplanting in the areas that
we're gonna that are in the plastic
mulch in that as those crops are
available and then manage them by mowing
it and also you're flushing a lot of the
annual weed seats of the clover so it's
a technique you're managing your weed
seed bank with the clover and again
there's no bare soil here there's no
bare soil cultivation that but the
clover is not interfering with you know
your cash crop in this place in this
case eggplant and then here we are early
October taking the plastic out
not easy you know there's really not an
easy way to get that plastic out in this
case I was using bio teller but in other
fields you're using kind of non bio
telecom to conventional plastic mulch
but getting that plastic out and then
with what the light and that migrates in
and so there's no fall tillage and you
have a good stand of clover in that in
that field and then modification of this
in tomatoes this is a johnie's and that
same thing basically start off with a
bare soil seed your your oats and medium
red clover and then here we're using
straw mulch instead of plastic so this
is straw mulch that we had bailed at our
farm and first the clover notes are
established and then we transplant the
tomatoes and the bare soil important for
that bare soil to be warm so the soil
can warm up where we are and then then
bring the mulch into the tomato plants
you can see the straw mulch with the
with the clover strips and then the
management again with mowing and that so
we're flushing or annual weeds through
there but what I liked about this with
the straw mulch and saw the plastic with
a plastic we'd have a little weed kind
of a weed strip right on that edge a net
and created a kind of a challenge for
managing those weeds on that strip but
with the with the straw mulch and that I
could drive my tractor tire onto that
onto that straw and and I you know the
management of the weeds and that end
that field with the straw instead of the
plastic and that was phenomenally faster
just run that mower through the Eric and
run it right up on the straw and have
nice airflow good harvest aisles for the
tomatoes a net you notice how they would
you know well-established field and then
and then in the fall
take out the stakes and the string
tomatoes mow it and and then you have
kind of straw and I found that the I
didn't get the the migration of the
clover into the straw it really seemed
to impede a little bit I think if we use
less straw
probably get better migration of it but
point is is that a nice cover going into
the winter and good stands of clover
then this this year we planted our
winter squash and pumpkin nursery into
those clover strips without any
additional fertilizer natin had a you
know a hundred a crop of that had very
good crops of pumpkins and winter squash
from the clover that was established the
previous year but you know the key is
that there is almost no tillage for two
years and almost no bare soil for two
years once you do the initial setup of
the field in that and so it works well
on you know crops like sunflowers cut
flowers again we're flushing annual
weeds through the clover just wider
spacing and after a couple of mowings
the in that case the amaranth is gone I
found this technique works really well
for a gallon saga I've read that the
gallon Saugus seed has a very short term
viability about a year and a half and so
if you have fields that are infested
with gallon Soga if you can shut off all
kind of cultivation and tillage for two
seasons you can really blow a hole in
your weed seed bank a viable gallon
soldier seed so if you can use this
technique with the clover and at the
gallon so go we'll just it'll head out
just above the clover and so you just
mow it you just clip off those heads do
it four or five times and then there you
know then you can you know there'll be
no gallon saga in that field plus all
the weeds I mean the clover seed and I'm
sorry the the gallon so see that's in
the soil that is breaking down a net so
this is a great technique to eliminate
gallon so go in a vegetable farm which
is a problem in a lot of vegetable farms
induced by all that cultivation of bare
soil another way just to think about
cover crops is how to phenomenon as
actually turn cover crops into cash a
cash crop a variable cash crop so for
many years I've utilized field Peas
as a as a summer fallow nurse with oats
just spin it on three two one two three
three parts of fuel peas 2 1 part oats
I've done trials of about 15 varieties
of feel peas and I'm looking for a
tender and juicy and and non powdery
mildew susceptible variety of fuel
pianet and and maximum at Johnny's is
one varietal and many varieties that
don't work so well and and after about
four weeks of growth with the fuel peas
when they first come out the shoots are
tough so you need to have enough growth
and so that that with your finger you
can snap them when they snap and that
then they're tender and it's a great
stir fried green it's very popular in
Asian cuisine also a kind of new
American chefs I used to sell to 35
restaurants and so I was getting nine
ten dollars a pound for the pea shoots
for the restaurant trade but it was the
only thing I sold straight wholesale
market terminal Chelsea Market Terminal
to a broker the market terminal I was
getting 450 a pound for my broker there
and I was selling you know from 40 to 80
cases a week through the market terminal
and so I would stagger my ceilings of
fuel piece of notes to try to extend my
my supply of the fuel peas and oats for
that cash crop value as well as getting
all the benefits of having this fallow
field of you know tillage weed
suppression you'd get off that buildup
of organic matter and also the nitrogen
that come off the fuel B's in that as
the maximum Brian or a few other
varieties of field Peas and that you
know that the the flowers at different
colors and that I found the chef's
really liked the purple flower you got
off the maxima and also just used that
little little point where the flower
isn't that and I would add that in my
salad mix it's a great bulking agent for
the salad mix and the pea flower is a
beautiful pea flavor and I was getting a
clam shell 50 count people options for
20 dollars a clam shell and selling many
hundreds of pounds I mean how many
hundreds of dollars a value off those of
people awesomes also as a white flower
some varieties that's kind of the that's
the length of the pshew
and then if I wanted to extend that
season you could use it for just get one
flush and then have cash crops come on
the back side of fuel Pisa and oats or
you could double up and designate a
whole field for a whole season than that
and so a lot of the acreage that's what
I would do I would let the oats and the
fuel pee mature but it wouldn't have to
be combine mature just just start to
have a bit of a seed coat to it and then
I would mow it I use the Spader one pass
of the Spader which is a less aggressive
tillage tool but you know it is it still
has a tillage group tool for certain so
that's one pass the Spader get that
residue into the ground you need
moisture to sprout it so you need to do
it with rain whoops
or with irrigation and then here's your
second flush later in August and then
you have another another round going
into the fall of your pea shoots and
that as well as all that biomass very
dry last two years of Johnny so
definitely had to irrigate an in
midsummer there it is a Johnny's really
nice flushed back in August and then
then that will winter kill if we have my
you know if you have a mild fall in that
you don't want the oats in that second
flush to set maturity to that so you
might mow it down as that oat seed if
it's a little juicy you want to mow it
down before it hardens up and that so
you don't have a problem with that as a
volunteer or the next spring and then I
found that I used a much less aggressive
tillage after the fuel Pina no residue
and that kind of got wet and and soft
and that through the winter net very
easy to work for early spring crops and
that with no additional fertilization
other than you know adjusting for pH and
at and most of my direct seeded crops my
following spring would come off the
field piano fallow Sudan grass just a
great builder of organic matter and a
weed suppressant I want to see the thick
I'm broadcasting but you can just see
drill
what I found is that I may let the Sudan
grass get the full maturity and add its
so stocky and lignin it's hard to break
it down through the winter the next year
and that so I would mow it three times
not let it get any higher than waist
high and also it would I find that it
would the root mass and that would get
thicker from that mowing in that you'd
have you know no weeds in that
understory of the Sudan grass and then
sometimes I wanted to with this this
summer foul and that get a clover
established in the backside and so just
before my third mowing I would drop
medium red clover seed into the Sudan
grass and the mowett so that the
resident would be a mulch and then
here's the stuff my first year I get it
and that you know part of the field they
just did it straight Sudan grass let it
winter kill and the other part of the
field I did this technique and now I've
used I've used it up in johnny's it
works really well on if you have kind of
dry sandy soils on that that mulch and
that is a nice kind of nurse material
for that clover underneath it than that
and then you'll have a nice stand of
clover they'll take you into the next
next spring buckwheat tom has talked
about that it's just it's a great great
interruption summer cover crop great
smother crop it's also really good for
harboring beneficial insects bees and
otherwise and so I would always in in
fields of this case Brussels sprouts but
in Nebraska fields that every xx bed and
that I would put a bed of of buckwheat
stagger those beds and they would be
insect II areas and had to bring my
beneficial is in I found that there's a
predator wasps it likes to crack open
the back of imported cabbage worm
Annette and so if you have these little
stands of flowering buckwheat in that
it's a great attractant for bringing in
some of these these wasps and that that
really can knock out your cabbage worms
and that also they're great great crop
for honeybees
Kim stoner and the Connecticut
Experiment Station that has done a lot
of work on evaluating different cover
crops and what beneficial insects they
bring in and this is kind of a hard
slide to read an app but the point of it
is is that she was looking at at
honeybees and in bumblebees bumblebees
build their nests in the ground so
ground tillage and that disturbance on
that is going to take that need of be
out of you're off your farm and that
honeybees of course you know they were
managing honeybees with Europe be high
and that but not all flowering cover
crops are going to attract the the same
same insect canet so for medium red
clover net it's attractive to bumble
bees but not honeybees and as opposed to
say buckwheat is is attractive to
honeybees but not bumblebees and there
are few of these flowering cover crops
like white clover that attractive to
both honey bees and bumblebees so it's
kind of like know your bees and know
your cover crop and and you can use them
to bring in something into your into
your fields and buckwheat is great it's
really easy to knock down I really like
buckwheat he's a setup for fall carrots
and at to really clean your soil up for
direct seeded carrots and that it's just
a great setup crop for that and and
again I found that if I'm not gonna put
a fall crop in the backside of a
buckwheat net just before you move that
flowering buckwheat down if you can drop
medium red clover down then mow it and
then run a coldie Packer over you get a
nice stand of clover take you into the
into the fall equipment and that for
cover crops it's good that you know you
want to match up the width of your
implements to your bed bed widths on
that so you can work with these strips
and that it's also important that if
you're going to set aside cropland to
cover crops and that you know it they're
not you know run by automatic pilot you
need to manage them irrigation is very
important to be able to kind of mitigate
drought stress on cover crops and so you
want to think about that and
you know and so that there's a
commitment to getting these cover crops
in not as an afterthought so all my
equipment will kind of match up for my
purposes of using cover crops and that
and the bed width of my tractors I mean
an implement that we brought in to
johnny's that was discovery for me it's
very stony soil for a lot of fields we
had there so I guess Bader would not
work well therefore cutting strips and
so this is kind of like a hybrid
perfecter than that but instead of
having those s tine sweeps and that it
has two gangs of disks then you have the
rakes and the roller bar in the back but
it's great for cutting strips if you get
in there early and makes a nice level
seed bed and also it's a nice nice bed
to also be laying plastic on all kinds
of implements for seeding and that from
fertilizers spreaders to see drills we
do a lot of Racine just by by hand
Cedars nothing wrong with that it's a
nice feel that was seated with the see
drill but when I'm using the see drill
and spinning home you know almost every
time I'm putting cover crops on because
I really want to get a good catch in
that I'll put a coldie packer on the
backside I think that called a packer in
the backside just a good guarantee that
you get good seed to soil contact and
and you want to seed with moisture
either either moisture is coming are
there's good moisture in the field to
get a good stand you do not want to seed
in kind of desert dry conditions that's
a recipe for disaster with with cover
crops
and just pictures of Kovac you can buy
coldly Packers without without seed seed
hoppers and that I'll just kind of skip
quickly and just to end a net burn
talked about this but there uh you know
I've been thinking recently there's a
lot of high tunnels that Johnny's and
that looking for ideal candidates a high
tunnel environment so I'm looking for
something that might be a legume might
have something to do with with bio
fumigation easy to manage easy with hand
tillage a knock down so fenugreek is one
it's a thirty five day leg you it's also
a high valley cash crop for East Indian
community whoops that's what it looks
like here it is in a high tunnel and
other ones by OPM to get mustards than
that and easy to manage very thick and
cut and come again and with that well
will stop as I'm over time here this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu